um the issue of
commitment came up for us in
conversation
today the commitment i speak of is the
commitment
that accompanies the creative act that
asks for nothing less than everything
now this can play out
um in a in a creative incubator while
making music or writing songs but it can
also be the creative act of surfing a
wave or hurling yourself off a mountain
at 50 miles per hour on a mountain bike
there is again
a moment of commitment or a leap of
faith a trust fall
that asks for nothing less than
everything and we can only
know wholeness i believe through the
enactment of this
commitment only through full commitment
can we know wholeness even though the
price is nothing less
than everything and it asks for nothing
less than everything most of us
don't live as if we can't take it back
every one of our actions is neutered by
uh by by an emergency exit there's
always a hinge that we can
pull and parachute ourselves from this
experience and so
we don't actually live in full
commitment at all even when we
marry there's a divorce clause there's
always
a way out there's always a way to take
it back but i think the people
who live more fully tragic stories as
they
are are often people who live as if
there's no
turning back for every moment is dying
to who you were
the full commitment asks for nothing
less than everything and
it for me today it played out riding a
bicycle while listening
to music while ecstatically receiving
the sky wanting to lick the sky and what
happened was annihilatory it was like a
fusion of two
atoms what was what were discrete and
separate elements you know the bicycle
the ride myself and the song playing
were all fused together and action and
awareness became one
thing i was fully committed and there
was no turning
back it asked for nothing less than
everything but in retrospect
i felt more alive in that moment than i
usually do but i also realized that in
that moment i was no longer in control
right something else was going through
me it wasn't from me and though it was
with me it belonged not to me but i felt
ecstatic
in its surrender i felt captured by its
grace
right i actually felt liberated by
commitment
most of us we step over to the ledge we
go to the edge of the ledge
and we consider the possibility but
we're always able to tiptoe
back there's always a harness or a hinge
there's a way of saying
i'll kind of dip my toe in but i always
reserve the right of admission i always
reserve the right to take it back and
what happens is
we kind of live a half life right the
truly brave and bold amongst us are the
ones that hurl themselves off mountains
wearing wing suits they
put everything on the table they're
raising the stakes and they're living
like it matters
and they probably are privy to
rhapsodies that most of us will never
know
and the sadness of that is that we'll
never know what it's like to be jimi
hendrix doing his guitar solo while
peeking on
acid in a moment of ecstatic ego death
we'll never know what it's like to hurl
ourselves
off airplanes while skydiving until we
do so
and if you cannot submit friends you
cannot die and if you cannot die you
cannot be reborn
and so the commitment unfortunately is
required the price of entry
asks for nothing less than everything if
you want a creative life if you want
exquisite surrender if you want ecstatic
catharsis you're going to have to hurl
yourself on the cross
you're going to have to hang yourself on
the cross and willingly die again
and again and again this is from the guy
that fears death
you know is is the guy that fears death
the guy who never
danced at parties realizes that the
pleasure to be found
when dancing at parties because serious
times call for furious dancing
is is a is a is a space i've never
tasted
you know it's a space i sometimes i
sometimes
get a whiff off a perfume from in these
brief
interludes of surrender but i recoil
back into myself and i'm like
a ptsd patient you know in a hyper
vigilant
stupor you know oscillating between
boredom and anxiety when what he really
wants to do is make
the commitment right because as mckenna
said nature loves courage the irony of
all this hesitation is that nature
loves courage you make the commitment
and nature responds to that commitment
by removing impossible obstacles
you dream the impossible dream and the
world will not grind you under it will
lift you up they say this is the secret
what all the philosophers professors
what the wise men knew
what they understood the alchemical gold
right the shamanic
dance in the waterfall this is how magic
is done you hurl yourself into the abyss
and you realize that it's a feather bed
easier said than done no doubt but this
is the truth from which nothing can
dislodge us at the end of the day we
know it to be true friends
that that the commitment is is is is
non-negotiable that if you haven't um
if you yeah if you haven't um fully
committed
you haven't lived a life at all
what do you think edgar for sure
yeah true true commitment yet uh
yeah through commitment uh has no way
has
no turning back that's the point that's
a true commitment correct
when you don't when you can't correct
when you
when you take the dose yes it's the
effects are start to show it
themselves and you're like no no no no
that's correct i don't want to do this
anymore that's correct i changed my mind
but that's it hey look
yes i'm sorry you're just going to have
to ride it out yes
correct the only way out is through
breakdown to break through you know when
i took a lesson
in free diving in tulum you know free
diving
is the act of holding your breath and
then down regulating your nervous system
when the panic impulse kicks in and the
resistance and the fear
and the gasping and grasping for air
right and it's and it's an involuntary
reflex it's a survival mechanism
stepping off from the ledge
getting up for air and what they teach
you eventually is to learn
to literally down regulate your nervous
system and your panic response
and to push through thresholds where you
experience a kind of psychological death
the final exercise in the free diving
class required going down stabilizing
and then
going underneath this cave structure
that was like i don't know maybe two or
three meters
long it wasn't very far but it was a
full commitment in the sense that once
you decided to go for it
there was a point where the other end
was closer than going back
but there was there was a feeling that
you might not be able to
hold your breath that long even though
the instructor is there to make sure
you are physiologically able to but you
still push through a threshold where you
feel like you've hit your limit you
really haven't but you feel like you
have
and when you realize there's no turning
back there's a kind of transcendence
because when you finally commit to it
and you realize that you're gonna go for
it even if i don't know that i'll make
it
right you believe that illusion and you
push through anyway
right you think you might die and you do
it anyway
and only in that moment of total
commitment when everything is laid on
the line psychologically
do you transcend yourself and when you
come out oh my god
it's dmt released all over the brain
it's absolutely ecstatic the instructor
was like okay jason just float
in the water and look at the sky like
you just crossed a threshold
and and it is this that we're all
trying to do in our lives i'm this is
what we're all talking about this is
what the wellness movement is about and
the breath working the psychedelics and
the healing and the coming into
wholeness this is what we're all
doing this is what we're all talking
about this is what's become in
vogue it's like how do we make ourselves
whole well friends again i think it
comes from realizing that we've got to
commit
we've got to leap we've got to trust
right and this is the only way
the only way the only way there is no
other way
this is the way that's right that's
right
so thanks for listening and may you
bring
commitment and wear withhold and courage
um into all facets of your life